funny how what the funny how funny how  yes now that came actually that's good  Fellas and that actually came from  something that I that happened to Joe  Pesci funny how I mean what's funny  about it  Tom you know you got it all wrong oh  Anthony  he's a big boy he knows what he said  what'd you say funny how I heard it was  I'm not gonna say not scripted but it  was semi-improvised let me put it this  way he described the the incident to me  we then rehearsed it  several times okay wrote it up in  different versions and then composed the  scene from those rehearsals so it was  scripted in that sense uh with the  Frills here and there okay  and now it's a classic yeah tell me  what's funny  get the [ __ ] out of here to Tommy